welcome back I'm not going to do a
presentation on how to essentially
invert the chain rule or reverse the
chain rule because where we're doing
integration which is the opposite of
taking the derivative so let's just take
a review of what the chain rule told us
before if I want to take the derivative
if I were to take the derivative of F of
G of X hopefully this doesn't confuse
you too much I'll give an another
example with concrete f of X and a
concrete G of X I want to take the
derivative of that the chain rule just
says that the derivative of this
composite function is just the
derivative of the inside function G
prime of X times the derivative of the
outer or kind of the the parent function
oh but still having G of X in at times F
prime of G of X I know this might seem
complicated if you're not if you aren't
too comfortable with this type of
notation but you not in kind of an
example form it makes a lot of sense if
I said what is the derivative of what is
the derivative of let's say sine of x
squared well in this situation f of X is
sine of X right and then G of X is x
squared right and sine of x squared is
essentially F of G of X so and then this
is just a review of the chain rule you
could go watch the video on the chain
rule as well but I don't mind with a
couple problems here so all this is
saying that the derivative of this is
you take the derivative of the inside
function G of X in this example which is
2x and you multiply it times the
derivative of the outer function or the
parent function and we memorize I guess
that the derivative of sine of X is
cosine of X so it's times cosine of G of
X so we keep the x squared there right
if it confuses you just think about the
inside and the outside function if you
take the derivative of kind of this
composite function it's the same thing
but that equals the derivative of the
inside function which is 2x times the
derivative of the outside function but
we keep this inside function in it then
we keep this x squared there so that's
that's a review of the chain rule so
what happens if we want to reverse the
chain rule well if we wanted to reverse
it we're essentially saying that we want
to take the integral of something where
we have the derivative of kind of the
inner function and then we have the
derivative of a larger composite
function right I'm just rewriting the
chain rule but I'm writing in an
integral form that this is equal to F of
G of X right
this statement up here is the exact same
thing as this statement down here right
all I did is I took I took the integral
of both sides right I'm saying this the
integral of this is equal to the
integral of this right here I probably
shouldn't have switched equal signs like
that with you but let's let's use this
formula I guess but all you have to know
is this is this the reverse of the chain
rule to solve some problems image invert
colors okay so all I said let's see let
me rewrite that the integral if I have G
prime of x times F prime of G of X DX
that that is equal to F of G of X this
is just the chain rule in Reverse and I
know it's very complicated sometimes
when you have it in this notation but
I'll give you a couple of examples what
if I had the integral let's say this is
actually one that's often kind of viewed
as a trick but you'll see it's actually
not that tricky
okay so let's say I have the natural log
the natural log squared over X DX and if
you saw a derivative if you saw an
integral like this you'd probably be
daunted and you'd be surprised many
people well into college calculus
courses are still daunted by this
problem but all you have to recognize is
this is the reverse chain rule why is
this the reverse chain rule well this is
the same thing as the integral of 1 over
x times the natural log
whoops this it should be NL x right the
natural log of x squared DX right these
are the same thing I just took the 1
over X out now this might look a little
familiar well what's the derivative of
the natural log of X if you remember
from the driven model it's 1 over X
right let me write that down let me
write that in the corner here write the
derivative of the natural log of X is
equal to 1 over X right so right here we
have the derivative of the natural log
of X so now we can just say that we can
essentially treat this natural log of X
as kind of a variable by itself and
essentially what I'm going to be doing
is I could acadec sure you substitute
for it actually let's do that let's do
that what I don't want to do that now
because that'll confuse you although
that my flip-flopping is probably
confusing you even more anyway I have
the derivative of the natural log of X
so I can then say well I have the
derivative there so this is a composite
function this is this is essentially F
prime of G of X right so then I can say
well did this that integral that
integral must be equal to this thing
this is something squared right so
what's the integral of something squared
well some integral of something squared
is 1/3 that's something to the third
power right we learned in the previous
indefinite integral module right and
then it's 1/3 something to the third
power and then we know from the chain
rule that
thing is the Ln of X Ln of X and and I
don't know if I've already forgotten to
do it once but don't forget to do the
plus see now that you say Sal this
completely confused me because it
probably did and if it completely
confused you let's just take the
derivative of this and I think you'll
see it happening the other way around
and it might make a little sense when
you take the derivative we just use the
chain rule you take the derivative of
the inside first the derivative of the
inside is 1 over X and you multiply that
times the derivative of the outside
function and then you keep the inside
the same so the derivative of the
outside function is 3 times its
coefficient so it's 3 times 1/3 times
the whole thing - one less exponent so
the whole thing is Ln of X and then of
course plus 0 right the derivative C is
0 well this is just equal 3 3 cancel out
this is equal to 1 over x times the ln
of x squared which is our original
problem let me do another problem
because I probably started off with
something a little bit too hard what is
the integral of let's say sine of X to
the third power DX that's often written
like this that's often written like sine
of X same thing but I like to think of
it this way because it's not a new
notation so um Oh something actually
this is a mistake I'm clearly I'm making
up these problems on fly I actually
don't want to do that that is the wrong
problem I want to take the integral and
actually you can see kind of how I'm
thinking about these problems I want to
take the integral of cosine of X times
cosine of X times the sine of X
to the third power DX well we have this
kind of more complicated part the sine
of X and we have we have the derivative
of sine of X right because we learned
the derivative sine of X is closed
affect cosine of X so if we have a
function inside of a larger composite
function and we have its derivative we
can just treat this function as kind of
like a single entity and then like as if
this was just one variable right and so
we and then we take the integral of it
so this is this equal to sine of X and
we raise this one more power to the
fourth and we multiply it times one
fourth right and how did we do that
because we know that the integral of say
X to the fourth DX is equal to I mean X
to the third DX is equal to one fourth X
to the fourth but instead of an X we had
a sign here and remember the reason why
we did that is because the derivative of
the sine function is sitting right here
in the next presentation I'll show you
why this can also be done using
substitution or why they're the same
thing I'll see you in the next
presentation